hmm
good afternoon everyone please be seated
i hope everyone enjoyed their lunch
we're ready to proceed with the first
witness mr shellhorn please call your
first witness
judge the state we'll call corporal
derrick
good afternoon corporal please remain
standing for a moment place your right
hand on the bot left hand on the bible
excuse me raise your right hand please
listen to my court closer we'll
administer an oath do you say the
presence of almighty god the testimony
of this court regarding this matter
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing love the truth
please state your name by your last name
of the record corporal theraheimer
h-e-y-n-e-r thank you
all right have a seat officer please
keep your voice up nice and loud we have
jurors in the first two rows in the
gallery yes sir
we had to separate them from the jury
box so they need to hear all of your
testimony keep your voice up if you
don't understand a question please don't
answer it just ask counselor to rephrase
the question
and if you hear an objection during your
testimony please stop testifying until
the court laws on the objection yes all
right very good
go ahead mr shellhorn your witness
thank you i'm going to conduct some of
this questioning sitting down because
there are jurors sitting behind me so
they can see that's fine thank you
corporal can you please introduce
yourself to the jury and tell them where
you work corporal derek timer washington
township police in mars county
and how long have you worked there uh
nine years two months
now you indicated you're a corporal what
unit are you currently assigned to i'm
currently assigned to patrol
and how long have you been assigned to
patrol
my first six years and then since
january this past year were you assigned
to another unit uh prior to that yes
what was that detective bureau
approximately how long were you assigned
to the detective three years
i want to draw your attention back to
august 7th of 2019 were you working for
the washington township police
department that day yes and you recall
how you were dressed
hold on a second
can that
we need to mute that miss kupka
all right sorry for the interruption mr
sheldon go ahead thank you judge
a corporal i'll ask the question again i
want to draw your attention back to
august 7th of 2019 were you working for
the washington township police
department that day yes what was your
duties on that particular day that was
what's called the third party detail can
you explain to the jury what that means
third party details when a contractor
hires us either for security or traffic
on this day it was a tree training job
so we were there for traffic
do you recall how you were dressed that
day i had a bdu or class c uniform
so uh what class uniform are you wearing
today in court this is a b
and what would be the difference between
the class c and the class b the class c
looks similar if it has patches on each
arm
instead of a name tag your name's
embroidered on the right side of the
chest and there's an embroidered patch
on the left side for pants or cargo
pants with blue stripes on the side
now i'll uh draw your attention to
approximately 2 15 that afternoon when
you were working the third party detail
do you recall where you were yes can you
tell the jury that i was just over our
timeline into
lebanon
at a stainless steel valve company
parking lot
were there any other washington township
police working that duty with you that
day yes who was that oh jason hensley
was he dressed uh similar to you or
differently
at approximately 2 15 that afternoon did
you receive some sort of a dispatch
related to the address of 411 west mill
road yes how did you receive that
dispatch via the radio and what was the
nature of the dispatch somebody actively
shooting at that location
based on the uh
nature of the dispatch what did you do i
left that location and proceeded to
drive to the residence
were there any other law enforcement
officers or first responders at the
scene when you got there no
can you just
can you describe for the jury the
general layout of the property as you
would turn on to it from west mill road
i made it right out of the driveway
about 250 feet down the driveway on the
left-hand side there was a two-floor
white house
about 75 to 50 feet beyond that there's
a hillcrest and about 800 to a thousand
feet there's a barn in the back
it's
judge at this point i'd like to pull up
what's been marked for identification as
s 391
it's an aerial map of the uh property
and i don't believe there's an
not
objection
right
it's what do did you say it's 389 or
391. judge 389 is actually the diagram
which we will be using shortly but 391
is an aerial uh
now
okay
are you moving that into evidence now
yes please fine
no objection mr blinkus
state uh exhibit 391 will be accepted
into evidence that's an aerial map
corporal did that come up on the screen
in front of you as well yes it did
now
we're looking at s 391 on the big
screens for the jury
can you explain to them the orientation
of this map in terms of where west mill
road is
western roads the road labeled westmore
road on the left side of the screen
and where would the driveway onto 411
property uh be located on this it's the
large driveway that goes diagonally
across the center of the screen
just above where it says west millburn
now you indicated that you made a
right-hand turn onto the driveway yes
and does that mean that you would have
been coming on this map from the
direction where it says west mill road
and then making that first right onto
the driveway
yes
you had also indicated there was a
two-story house uh shortly after turning
on the driveway yes do you see that in
this or on this map yes can you tell the
jury where that is
if you follow that driveway
on the left-hand side there's a
little offshoot off the main driveway
and that's the house right there
based on the nature of the uh dispatch
that you were responding to when you
turned onto the driveway what did you do
opened my door and
removed my firearm from the holster
can you explain to the jury why you
opened your door
in the event that i had to stop suddenly
i could exit the vehicle right away
at some point did something catch your
attention while you were driving uh on
the driveway yes right near the
right near the hillcrest i saw a
older white male casually walking and
speaking on what appears to be a
telephone
and when you say uh near the hillcrest
um can you describe for the jury where
that would be on the map of s 391 if you
follow the driveway from westmill road
on the left you pass the residence and
then there's some a group of trees
before you hit that field on the left
right in that area
standing near the driveway
based on seeing that person walking
there what did you do
i began to continue driving down the
driveway um
and as i did that the person that i saw
walked over the hillcrest out of my
vehicle
and so on s391 that would have meant the
person was walking
in the in the right towards the right
side of the diagram yes toward the bar
is located in the back
did you hear anything at that point or
around that point that caught your
attention yes can you explain that to
the jury i heard somebody they'll help
and approximately where were you when
you heard that
i was in the area of that
was on the main driveway in the area by
the um the offshoot to the parking area
[Music]
meaning that it would have been uh to
your left hand side yes and that was the
same side that your door was open
towards yes that's correct
after you heard that what did you do
next i put the vehicle in forward and
get out of my vehicle at this point
could you see any people no what did you
see in that driveway i saw a silver ramp
pickup truck pulled head-on into that
driveway
did you proceed down the driveway in the
direction that you said that you heard
the voice yes
what did you do as you went past the
brand pickup truck i checked to confirm
that nobody was inside the vehicle was
there anybody no
at some point did you
get to the front of the pickup truck yes
can you tell the jury what you saw
to my left
there was a
there were a couple windows in the back
of the house there's a back door on the
right with a small set of steps
in the area of the patio on the steps
when the two men are lying out the back
and one male on top of another male a
couple of feet um it would have been to
the right that i was looking at
at that time did you know who any of the
individuals were no did you come to find
out who they were during the subsequent
investigation after things settled down
yes
can you tell the jury who you came to
learn that the female was lord cataract
and you indicated that there were two
men there yes
uh
starting with uh the man who was on the
ground did you come to learn who that
was yes who was that michael barrasso
and do you see that individual in court
today yes could you identify that person
by an article clothing for
white shirt and yellow tie
identifying your defendant michael
barrasson for the record
did you uh eventually come to learn who
the second male was yes who is that
robert goodwin
now you described that you came around
the silver truck you saw this scene in
front of you approximately what was the
distance between you
and where these people were
maybe around 20 feet
and do you recall approximately how
close they were to one another
with a couple of feet two or three feet
what did you do when you saw that
i saw that i asked out loud i yelled
where's the shooter
mr goodwin the man on top replied here
i asked again
he was
on top of mr barriss on the back he
shook him by his shoulders and said this
is the shooter now you indicated before
uh that when you pulled onto the
driveway you had already pulled out your
gun based on the nature of the the
dispatch yes did you still have your gun
out at this point yes
what did you say or what did you do
rather when you were told that that was
the situation mr
goodwin get off of mr barrison at which
time he grabbed a small dog that was in
the area picked the dog up as he did
that he came to my left and i made my
way to mr barrison
what was the defendant doing at that
point
the defender was lying on the ground
did you make any contact with him yes
and can you tell the jury what you did
i while i was making my way over there i
asked what a gun was
um mr goodwin
uh i don't i'm not sure verbatim but
something that affected it was
underneath him
i rolled mr barriston onto his right
side and his left his left his right arm
was visible his left arm was under his
torso i rolled him to his right side i
could see his hand was open and the gun
was lying next to him
can you describe what you saw
can you describe the gun yes it was a
black and pink hanger
based on the nature of the call and
seeing that gun what did you do
i
picked the gun up removed the magazine
pulled the slide back
a couple of times it was already slopped
back just confirmed it was empty i
pulled a slide a few times
i took a gun to my left near a gravel
pit that was in the driveway and the
magazine from my right which was toward
my vehicle
approximately how far away were you at
that point from
war in canada maybe two or three feet
and what was your position with respect
to the defendant michael bearson i was
standing um
saying to his right
i'm sorry he's left
were you doing anything uh in order to
restrain him
uh i checked him for weapons um just in
front of there was no other gun or
anything that could hurt me um
and that was and then he stayed on the
ground
at some point did any other officers
arrive uh to that area yes do you recall
who that was officer john werkenberg
and you recall what happened when
officer john wardenberg arrived when he
arrived he asked me what i needed i
asked that he'd get chest seals
out of one of the cars what are chest
seals which is seals it's a
piece of adhesive plastic that you put
over any
chest or
abdominal penetrating wound prevents
hair from getting into or out of the
chest cavity and collapsing along why
did you ask him to get chest ceilings
now he's missed counteract i saw two
gunshot wounds in her upper left chest
what did officer wordenberg do he went
back to my vehicle and obtained my uh
mountain back
which i was in and then brought it back
to
when he got back uh
what did you do next we hang up mr
where did you turn your attention after
handcuffing the defendant
back to the victim
and what did you do in terms of uh
providing any treatment i held some
pressure on her chest wounds and then um
finally riled up with a couple of other
officers sergeant burns corporal pelini
and officer barnes we applied the chest
seals
and
tended to a gunshot wound in her hand
the right hand are you aware at some
point whether uh other
officers then arrived on scene yes and
are you a whether we're excuse me aware
whether any emergency medical uh arrived
on scene yes did you see what the
emergency medical did
uh yes i was with miss cannery
approached us and they tended to her and
then put her on her stretcher and prefer
did you see if treatment was provided to
the defendant at all yes
and can you can you describe that for
the jury um
mr barristone officer henson with mr
barriston in the middle of the driveway
that parking area
prior to receiving medical treatment he
was moved to the side of the trailer in
the area he was seated against there
there was medical personnel near him i'm
not sure exactly what they were doing
do you recall what your observations of
the defendant were uh at that point yes
did he tell the jury he had blood on his
face and uh what appeared to be a
laceration on his forehead
are you aware whether mr goodwin
received any treatment at the scene i'm
not sure
now you indicated that the defendant uh
was handcuffed by you and officer
ortenberg
and i think you then said that you
turned custody of him over to officer
hensley yes that's correct
do you recall where the defendant was
handcuffed
in the back hands were handcuffed behind
his back
judge at this point i'd like to show uh
the corporal s 214 i don't believe
there's any of that
what is 214 is that a
photograph or something else 214 is a
photograph
any objection mr blencus
are you moving that item into evidence
yes
ladies and gentlemen of the jury
normally
when an exhibit is marked in advance
it's shown to the witness especially a
photograph and
the witness will be asked without
displaying it to the jury
whether what's in the photograph fairly
accurately depicts
the scene of the crime or an image at
the time
it was taken and if the witness answers
yes it fairly accurately represents the
scene
the state would then move it into
evidence
and the court would um most of the time
accept that photograph and the evidence
counsel to save a little time council
have agreed and stipulated to the
admission of certain photographs
documents and things of that nature so
that's what mr shellhorn is referring to
now we're going to avoid
that step one so when you see that occur
there has been conversation the parties
are stipulating to the admission
of the photograph or the diagram into
evidence before this jury okay
so with that it's number two
14
will be accepted into evidence
for this trial
and it will be displayed for the members
of the jury on the screens in court
corporal do you recognize uh s-214
yes what is s-214 a picture of it's a
fixture from the main section of the
driveway toward the driveway that goes
behind the house in the small parking
area
and the vantage point that s214 is taken
from
uh can you describe where that is in
relationship to where you would have
parked or stopped your car it's in the
same area
i'm assuming but i want you to put it on
the record uh there's something
different about the way this picture
appears from when you arrived on scene
yes there was no police tape no gloves
the police car was a little lighter and
it hadn't rained that much at that point
now you indicated when you initially got
out of your car and came into this back
uh driveway area that you came around uh
yeah is that the silver pickup truck
you're referring to yes it is
judge steve would like to
move in to evidence s
389 you have a stipulation for this uh
item
it is a
diagram
right
ladies and gentlemen with regard to the
next item that will be displayed for you
it's state exhibit
389 389 there is a stipulation by the
parties
and the stipulation means as follows the
parties have agreed to certain facts
and the jury should treat these facts as
undisputed
i.e the parties agree that these facts
are true
as with all evidence however
undisputed facts can be accepted or
rejected by the jury in reaching their
verdict
now with regard to the stipulation the
state and the defendant stipulate and
agree to the following
the parties agree that if detective
corporal max engel alert
or englart of the morris county
sheriff's office crime scene
investigations unit
known by the acronym of mcso hyphen csi
would it be called as a witness during
the trial he would testify that he
processed
and mapped an area at 411
west mill road washington township new
jersey
specifically
an area encompassing the driveway
the farmhouse and the parking area in
the rear of the farmhouse
detective corporal
englert would further testify that he
prepared two diagrams
of this area
which is attached to this stipulation as
exhibit one
and exhibit two
accordingly it will be it will not be
necessary for the state of new jersey or
the defendant
mr barrison to call corporal angler to
testify as to the authenticity of the
diagrams identified herein
so the parties have stipulated to the
authenticity of the two diagrams and
we'll begin
389 diagram one go ahead mr shellhorn
and ladies and gentlemen before we
proceed you will have i i just read to
you from a formal stipulation you will
have that in the jury room with you to
consider as part of the evidence in this
case go ahead mr shellhorn
thank you honor uh corporal have you
seen s 389 before
yes what is s 389 it's an overhead
diagram of the
main driveway the parking area behind
the house and the house
and is this a fair and accurate uh
diagram
of what you encountered at the scene of
411 west mill road on august 7 2019. yes
now you indicated that you had parked uh
your patrol vehicle
uh somewhere on the driveway where is
that located on s389
uh main driver on the left right around
where it says driveway that area right
where the main driveway meets the
driveway in the back of the house
and when you indicated that you had
proceeded behind uh
behind the farmhouse by the truck do you
see the silver truck represented on the
sidewalk yes can you tell the jury where
that is it's the red truck labeled fl
reg i f
7 o u e
as you came around
that truck and you indicated that you
saw miss canara mr goodwin and the
defendant can you describe the and
explain to the jury the approximate area
where you saw those three individuals
the back of the house where it says back
door the small set of steps
they were if you're looking at the steps
just to the left over there
and
ordinarily uh corporal i would ask you
judge would it be possible for the
corporal to come down and point that out
absolutely thank you purple we do have
two streams we have one here and there's
another one behind me so if i could ask
you to point it out first on the screen
in between the windows
and then i'll ask you to point it out
for the other jurors so you're going to
point out the approximate area where you
first encounter
or first observe will counteract
that would be right by where it says
back door on the what i'll call the
bottom right corner of the house yes all
right if you should come point that out
to the other jurors on the other side
thank you
is that the area that you described
earlier where you proceeded over and uh
were told that the defendant was the
shooter yes
is that the same area that you described
where you uh
rolled the defendant over picked up the
pink and black handgun removed the
magazine and threw them in different
directions yes
now you indicated that you had thrown
and i think you said that it was near a
gravel pile is that shown on this
diamond yes it is can you uh identify
that area for the jerk
it's the area labeled gravel pile by the
end of the driveway
that's sort of uh almost a circle there
on the right-hand side of the diagram
yes
which direction did you throw the
magazine in it's am i right
and do you see the approximate area
where you threw the magazine to on this
diagram yes i do can you tell the jury
where that is
it's the
next to the truck it's labeled mcso
number 10 magazine
and that item is actually
labeled on this diagram yes
judge if i could have permission to
approach with two items of evidence
certainly
i'll leave both of those with you now
but i want to direct your attention to
s-177 first
there should be a red
state sticker on it 177 yes
have you seen that item before yes what
is it is the handgun i located under mr
parasaur
and does that appear to be in the same
or substantially the same condition as
when you located it under the defendant
on august 7 2019 yes
is there anything different about it
has a gun lock on them is it high
those are for safety in the courtroom
yes
you didn't put those on no and those
obviously weren't on the day of the
shooting correct
should i have permission for the uh
corporal to
show that to the jury if it could be
moved into evidence
all right um item s-177 a handgun
uh in a evidence box will be admitted
into evidence and can be displayed to
the jurors
i want to hold that up so all the jurors
can see that officer please
just based on the distance from the
jurors he can he can walk back yeah
absolutely
a couple questions for you about that
gun you indicated when you recovered it
underneath the defendant that there was
a magazine in it can you tell the jury
what a gun magazine is
it's the photographer that holds the
rounds in it with the bullets
and where was the gun magazine located
on this particular boat
there was in the bottom it was loading
at the bottom of the handle in the
bottom of the handle
and were you able to uh eject that
magazine yes do you recall if there were
any bullets located in that magazine uh
yes there were no bullets in it
now with respect to the
state or condition of the gun itself
i think you had indicated something
before about the slide can you explain
to the jury what your understanding of
the slide on a handgun like this is
as slight as this top piece that's slid
back typically you want to run a gun um
i'm sorry i'm sorry interrupt yes sir
when you do that yes sir just i know
what you're used to everyone's sitting
here but we have jurors on the side if
you can just stand up feel free to stand
up hold that up nice and high so all of
the jurors can see it yes sir all right
just slides this black piece in the top
here typically when a gun goes empty um
the slide will lock back not always but
on most guns it will
and that was locked back where i located
it
when you said that you ejected the
magazine and then you pulled the slide
back several times what does that do or
why did you do it um
it's really out of habit
of shooting a lot you always want to
make sure the gun's definitely empty so
you typically pull a slide back just to
confirm that there's no more rounds in
it
and would that be if there was a round
inside the chamber of the the gun
yes what would happen if you had pulled
the slide back and there was still a
bullet in the chamber
the ground would eject itself
corporal next i'll draw your attention
to s
181 that you have in front of you there
and there are also some uh
sure
have you seen s181 before
i'll wait for you just
yes i have seen this before
what is that it's a magazine
does that appear to be the same magazine
that you ejected from the gun on august
7 2019 yes
judge at this point i'd like to move s
181 into evidence and have it shown to
the jury
any objections
s 181 will be accepted into evidence by
the court corporal you may show that
item to the jurors please yes
thank you corporal i don't
ask you to handle that anymore so if you
want to take off the gloves
now you indicated during the time when
you arrived on scene
to the rear of the house
that there was a dog
yes can you tell the jury uh what you
recall that the dog was doing when you
arrived on scene
i recall seeing it in the area
and
at one point it hit my left leg
did you have any injuries or or
uh receive any medical attention for
that
do you recall how
big or small the dog was
approximately 30 to 35 pounds
during the course of your interactions
there you indicated that
mr goodwin had uh
i guess retrieved the dog or recovered
the dog yes
now are you aware that there had been a
9-1-1 call placed from the scene before
you arrived
on that day
did you come to find out that there had
been a 911 call yes
and did you come to find out that that
call was still connected with
on 911 yes have you had a chance to
review that call yes okay and are you uh
familiar with at the end of that call
you being on the phone or on the 901
call
yes i was in the background yes
that call has been marked as s-113
it is the subject of a stipulation that
i handed up before the jury came into
court i would like permission to enter
that into evidence and play it
ladies and gentlemen as with the diagram
the parties in this case have entered
into a stipulation
and the stipulation is as follows
the parties agree that if catherine
hazel
operator 382 would be called as a
witness during the trial
she would testify
that a 911 call on august 7 2019
identified as s
113 and evidence is a fair and accurate
copy of the call received by her
accordingly it will not not be necessary
for the state of new jersey or the
defendant michael barrasson to call this
witnesses testify as to the authentic
authenticity of the august 7
2019 911 call
identified herein
all right thank you may
proceed that item 113 will be accepted
into evidence pursuant to stipulation of
counsel
thank you judge we'll play that now
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay officers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come here
oh
[Music]
is it just one person shooting
okay
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
his name is
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right now
[Music]
[Music]
sir where in the building are you
[Music]
[Music]
are you
[Music]
sure
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
corporal a few follow-up questions for
you related to that uh
that 911
did you arrive on scene and hear your
voice on that call
yeah we just listened to it
yes
have you ever responded to an active
shooter call before no
had you ever responded to a scene like
this before no
when you got on scene you indicated that
you saw uh
mr goodwin on top of the defendant yes
and you had indicated that he said uh
you asked where the shooter was and he
said right here yes did you hear that on
the call we just listened to yes
when an individual was saying
if you fucking move i'll fucking kill
you who was that that was me
who were you talking to mr barrison
are you indicated that when officer
wurttenberg got on scene you had asked
him to get chest seals yes
hear yourself asking for chest seals on
that call yes
now you indicated that
some other officers and emts besides
john wurttenberg
and jason hensley had arrived on scene
yes
and you also indicated that as other
individuals started to arrive on scene
that you are continuing to provide
medical help or assistance to lauren
canara yes
i'm going to show you again what's been
admitted into evidence as s 389
do you see the approximate area where
you uh were providing medical assistance
to ms kenorak on this uh diagram yes can
you tell the jury where that is
it's labeled as such on the side and it
was right in the area between that back
door
and the bush
right on the patio and that's where it
says approximate location of victim
medical treatment yes that's consistent
with
where you were when you were rendering
attention to her yes that was the
general area we were in
judge i'd like to show uh
circle hymer that's been
s206 for identification i don't believe
there's any
i don't believe there's any
uh objection to that all right
mr blinkist any objection
i've
s-206
to
numerous things that i'd like a uh an
exhibit list so i can see what this
falls into he's throwing out a number i
don't know
you prepared an evidence list right we
did judge does mr blinkus have one i
apologize if he didn't receive one i
could certainly find again but if it's
what we stipulated
all right there's no objection to s-206
that's a
photograph that's going to be displayed
the parties agree that that photo fairly
and accurately
depicts the scene
as it appeared when the photograph was
taken
and it's s-206 it will be admitted into
evidence
so they just provided a
copy of the evidence list all right very
good thank you
corporal we are now displaying what's
been marked as s-206
you've seen this picture before
yes if you could for the jury
and is this a fair and accurate
representation of the layout of the
scene when you were there on august 7
2019
yes as was the prior photo that you
identified is it fair to say that when
you were there there weren't necessarily
medical equipment uh gloves and evidence
measures that's correct
was it raining at the time
it was drizzling earlier i don't think
it was raining when i actually got there
now if you could for purposes of the
jury uh orient them to the location
where
the silver pickup truck would be
and the direction that you came from on
this picture the silver pickup truck
would be to the left parked in the
driveway
i came from around the other side of the
pickup truck when i emerged from the
front this is basically what i saw
and when you indicated that you saw
robert goodwin on top of the defendant
do you see that area in this picture
s206 yes can you tell the jury
approximately where that would have been
using perhaps something that you see in
the picture
looking at the medical bags to the right
of the medical bags
was where uh mr goodwin was on top of mr
barrison and are you able to see the
approximate area where you observed ms
lauren kenner yes
can you tell the jury the approximate
area where you observed her to be when
you first got on scene in the same area
as those medical bags
now you indicated that you were
the 911 call we just listened to that
you were dealing with the defendant uh
during the course of that 9-1-1 call yes
was that in the an area that you can see
on s206
oh yeah it was right in the area of the
steps so is it fair to say that your
interactions with these individuals
generally all happen in that same area
yes when i approached i spoke from a
little bit of a distance or toward the
truck
as mr goodwin got off mr barrissone
he came to my left and i made my way to
the right to mr barrasso
now you indicated that you and officer
wardenberg put handcuffs on the
defendant yes
and you indicated that you turned
custody over to officer hensley yes
and i think you also said that officer
hensley had taken the defendant to
another part of the property or another
part of the union
yes when we turned him over to him
he was in the middle of that parking
area and then moved by a trail after
that i'd like to show you what's been
marked as s 250
for identification judge this is another
photo
that i discussed with mr bolinkis and i
don't believe there's any objection to
the signature
ladies and gentlemen s250 will be
admitted into evidence
parties have stipulated to its
admissibility
corporal we're displaying s 250 for the
jury do you recognize what s 250 is a
picture of yes what is it
it's the trailer that mr barrison was
moved to um while being tended to by ems
and during the course of time that he
was being
attended to by the ems uh where was he
located with respect to this picture he
was leaning against the trailer
do you recall if he was re leaning in
the area of the left of the tire on the
tire or to the right of the tire
very cool
there are some clothing in the the
middle of the
picture there
uh do you recognize that clothing yes
what would that clothing be it's not mr
barisson's shirt
and was that the shirt that he was
wearing at the time that you arrived on
scene yes
corporal i'm going to direct your
attention back now to s389 we'll pull
that back up
do you see the area that we we just
looked at the picture of s250 the area
you indicated that the defendant had
received some medical treatment at the
scene do you see that area on s389 the
diagram yes i do can you identify that
area for the jury it's labeled as the
approximate location of suspect for
medical treatment the trailer is labeled
on there also
looks like trailer nc reg
ch55 i can't read the rest though and
that's basically in the center all the
way at the bottom yes
after uh medical personnel arrived on
scene and started
assisting ms kanorek did you continue to
participate in that or do something else
i stayed with miss canaric
how long did you stay with her
until she was placed on a stretcher and
uh put an ambulance i'm not sure the
time frame
now at that point did you go anywhere
else uh within this scene or in this
area yes what area of the scene did you
go to i walked the area where mr
barassone was receiving treatment
so if we're looking at s 389 you walk to
the area towards the bottom of the
diagram
yes
during this time do you recall if the
defendant was speaking with any medical
personnel
he was seated on the ground
there was medical personnel in the area
i didn't see him
he wasn't speaking with them at the time
they were speaking amongst themselves
do you recall whether you overheard him
making any statements during the time
you were in his vicinity yes i did can
you tell the jury uh what you
heard those statements to be
uh i had a good life
now do you recall uh whether the
defendant said that once or more than
once uh multiple times maybe two or
three times
and you just said that he had he stated
i had a good life was that a verbatim
statement or is that a summary of what
you recall him saying that's what he
said
were those statements made in response
to any questioning by you no any
questioning by law enforcement officers
besides you
any uh in response to any questioning by
medical personnel no
can you describe the defendant's
appearance or demeanor at the time that
he was making these statements
i just appeared impartial
not excited not upset not angry just
sitting there
did you have any issues understanding
the words that he used no
at some point uh did you leave the scene
yes can you tell the jury where you went
i went to hackett sound medical center
what was the reason for going there i
had mr barristones and miss counter
explode on my hands and arms
i went to
get a blood test on
did you ever come back to the scene yes
do you recall
in general approximately how long after
you came back
i don't recall it was several hours it
had gotten dark and uh
had been raining it's getting dark and
was raining
that was my next question when you got
back uh could you tell if it had been
raining yes
because i don't believe i have any other
questions uh for corporal heimer at this
time all right thank you can we leave
that diagram
cross-examination
corporal it's corporal right yes sir
corporal excuse me
you got a promotion since last time i
talked to you i did sir yes
congratulations thank you sir um
you indicated that you had to go to the
hospital for a blood test yes sir
and uh you had blood on you yes
whose floors was that
mr
barry
and ms canarics
now you indicated when you saw mr
barriston by that trailer that she was
pointed out here um
was it angry
was it upset correct no when i saw him
basically he was talking to himself at
that point yes sir
now
how close were
you to him when you heard him make those
statements a couple of feet away and and
did you observe
physical injuries
about his face his eyes
his forehead
his ear
i recall his his face having blood on it
and a laceration on his forehead i'm not
sure exactly where it was for him
and did you see a injury to
his ears
i don't specifically recall
now
you indicated that
on the seventh
your call was in response to an active
shooter correct yes sir and what does
that
actually mean to you in police
somebody at a location currently
shooting
and
is it fair to say that you got there
within a minute or so um
i had to go about a mile so yeah
approximately a minute or two maybe so
you respond to the scene
and when you get there
you see robert goodwin
on top of michael barrasson correct yes
sir
and was he beating him at that time no
was he
slamming his
face into the concrete path
no
did he appear angry
or upset
yes first observation he mean mr goodwin
yes mr goodman yes
you had no idea who the shooter was when
you first arrived on the scene correct
yes
and would you agree with me that uh
your department you were well aware of
that there were numerous previous
instances where michael barrasson had
called your department
correct i was aware of incidents down
there i'm not specifically aware of who
called on who but i know that we were
down there multiple times for landlord
attendant
issues and
you were aware that barriston was the
landlord under that scenario correct yes
now
when you got there
robert goodwin is on top of michael
barriston correct
yes
robert goodwin did not have a gun in his
hands at that time correct
no
when you saw michael barristone's
hand
he did not have a gun in his hand
correct
his hand was open under him and the gun
was lying right next to his hand okay
let's talk about that open hand
would you agree with me
that that open hand
was his left hand yes
and
based on your contact with michael
barrison would you agree
that that left arm of his had
broken or injured so severely
that it was
deformed
i didn't recall seeing anything unusual
but that
based on your recollection was the hand
that
was near that gun correct yes sir so
you arrive on the scene you have no idea
who the shooter is correct correct you
have no idea who
held the gun correct correct
and
you have mr goodwin get off embarrassing
correct yes
and
you allow him to go back into his house
at some point correct
at that point he did not while i was
not not at that immediate time though
well a short time thereafter while you
were dealing with mr barrison correct
at that point other officers were on
scene i'm not sure where
i know he went back into the house i'm
not sure what exactly that was
you and the other officers on the scene
allowed robert goodwin back into the
house correct
he said he didn't do it
you observed robert goodwin go back into
the house correct yes
now when you first observed
lauren camera
she was on the ground correct yes
and
would you agree that she was
incapacitated at that point yes
incapable of
and i'm referring to the state's diagram
running around this entire area
correct
physically incapable of running around
the house correct yes
was she physically incapable of uh
hand-to-hand combat at that point she
appeared today
when you say appear to be
she's lying on the ground with two
bullet holes in her correct yes
now
you guessed twice
who the shooter was correct yes
because you didn't know
correct
and the first time you were she weren't
clear one way or the other correct and
that's why you asked a second time yes
and robert goodwin readily
pointed to michael barrisson and said he
was the shooter correct
yes he shook him to indicate that he was
the shooter
now
when you got there
was that dog we heard yapping
incessantly
attacking michael barrison
no
where was that going
moments after
the call
don't summarize what the witness said
previously because that's not what the
witness said
he didn't say momentarily
he said it took him a minute or two
so
now he said a minute or two
so i don't want you characterizing in
your follow-up questions what a witness
says just ask your next question
when you arrived on the scene
the dog we heard yapping
where was he
i believe he was somewhere near the
gravel pile or the driveway
he was
when i was speaking with
mr goodwin yelling with mr goodwin the
dog was somewhere by the gravel pile and
then somewhere behind me
and so while you were on the scene you
never saw the dog near michael vance
and
at some point that dog starts attacking
you correct
yes
starts fighting at your leg or your boob
yes sir my left foot
did you ask robert goodwin to uh
command the dog off of you
i turned um well mr goodwin was still on
top of mr barris when i turned and
looked to my
look behind me
one way or the other
and uh mr goodman said not to hurt the
dog and i just shook the dog off my off
my leg
and do you have any idea why robert
goodwin asked you not to hurt his dog
objection
yeah how would this witness know that
well sustained ask another question did
robert goodwin ask you not to hurt his
soul after it started to attack you yes
now
at some point
you advise goodwin to get off of michael
barrasso correct yes
and
based on your observation
mr goodman was in complete control of
barrister when he asked him to do that
correct yes
so irrespective of how big he was and
how big barriston was
he was able to control michael barryson
correct yes sir
and michael barrasso wasn't fighting him
at that point when you first arrived
correct correct
now
you indicated that when you rolled
barisong over
you see the pink
gun
on the ground correct yes
were you advised by
robert goodwin that uh
[Applause]
don't get into
i understand the nature of the question
but don't elicit any specific statements
attributable to mr goodwin
you can indicate did you receive
information from mr goodwin
and and did you take any action as a
result thereof but don't don't get into
the specifics that would be here say so
it's sustained in part
but i'll allow you to ask a question in
a different way if you rephrase
um it you're there at the crime scene
did you see a camera
on this side of the house
at some point facing directly down where
this struggle took place
yes i do recall seeing a
seeing a camera in the area
and did you have any discussions with
anyone
about a camera possibly
capturing this
incident yes i did tell somebody i don't
remember exactly who that was but i do
recall telling other officers
and you said you came back
to the scene
did you relay that information in a
police report
um
i don't recall if i wrote that in my
report
uh
i'm going to have you refer to page two
if you report
what's the marking on it please
[Music]
yes
judge could i also ask for a copy of the
defendant's witness
exhibit list at a break
i don't have that
i didn't look at page two
hold on a second
let me see council at the bench please
[Music]
don't we have a clean report
i can't show this to a witness
do you have a
report copy report
have
clean
i need to get a clean copy of the report
i believe this is also a report an
unmarked copy
that's uh what was labeled by the state
as s1
for the record we're just on the process
of pulling that up to share with the
witness to a uh
breakout room
purple do you see the report yes sir if
you can go to page two
of your official
report
it's actually moving on its own
you okay
all right just take a minute and and
review that report to yourself please
the second paragraph
in what you're seeing right there
of the last sentence
you can look at that
and see if that refreshes your
recollection as whether you put in your
official report
if there was a possible
camera with the video of the incident
yes sir
i see that here
well i know you see it in your report
but now if you recall putting in the
official report that there was a camera
which captured the video possibly
yes
so
now
you were the first
officer on the team
correct
and you were the first one to see
michael barrisson from a law enforcement
standpoint correct yes
and would you describe your observations
of him
at that time
as being
incoherent
yes
and you put that in your official report
too correct yes sir
so
strike that
and it's your recollection when you were
handcuffing his left arm behind his back
that you notice no injury to that arm
correct that's correct
now
you indicated that michael barrasson was
being treated medically
um by people
um
when he was placed near that trailer
that you depicted on the state's exhibit
correct yes sir
and and would you agree with me that
there were a lot of people treating him
yes there were multiple ems members and
paramedics in the area
and near him
um did you see only being two feet of
way
um
what areas of his body they were
treating
when i was standing next to him well he
was seated the medical personnel were
talking amongst themselves and he was
just seated or leaning against that
trailer so i'm not sure exactly what
they were doing at that time
did he appear to be in excruciating pain
no he just appeared to be impartial and
was just
sitting there
and while he's over there it's your
recollection
that he
made the statement i had a good life a
number of times right yes do you have
any idea what he was referring to no sir
was he speaking to anyone that you could
see he didn't appear to be speaking to
anyone
sure
now
at some point in time
they take michael barriston's shirt off
him correct
yes
and being only two feet away were you
able to see
um the injuries on his body at that time
i was maybe about five or so feet away
and
i wasn't there very long i was only
there for a few moments
george i'd like to show this officer a
number of photographs
i don't believe the prosperous objection
all right
800 series
52-65 let me ask you to take a look at
these photographs
just by yourself
do those photographs
accurately depict what you observe
with respect to the injuries
michael byrosome
had on the day he responded
yes it looked accurate but when i saw
him water your call specifically was a
laceration and his face didn't have
blood all over
yes sir
thank
yes
you as a
trained police officer
realize that
that gun is empty yes sir
no bullets in it no sir
so when you saw the gun and saw his hand
somewhere near the gun
you were not concerned about him
grabbing the gun
and firing a projectile at you correct
no what's after possession of it
now
you were the afian
for the probable cause for the arrest of
him correct yes
and with regards to that
affidavit um
isn't it the fact that
robert goodwin did not see the shooting
hold on a sec
let me see council you know what we'll
take a quick break it's the afternoon
recess ladies and gentlemen we'll take a
quick ten minute break i'll address this
issue and then we'll resume
thank you
all right
next week
all right
do you have any other questions for him
um
yes
you